Destiny is definitely in the top 10 of influential political
left political commentators on the internet today. We found out
that the event was going to be canceled. I believe they're accusing
me of impropriety when their mascot has done multiple consent
violations, has multiple accusations from multiple women over
years. He thinks that Destiny did all those crimes and that every
woman that was willing to interact in the that way with Destiny
deserves it.
Take a quick look at this. Subs posted this today. Yesterday.
Andrew talking about apparently America was saying we're going
to support
Billy Crice Khan donating money to local lawyers. Oh, hold on.
What is this then? >> Andrew Wilson's a He's a Andrew Wilson's
a I mean, he's admitted on live streams before on his podcast.
>> my wife I don't know how many times, right? That's a
weird thing [clears throat] to admit.
live streams before on his podcast. >> my wife I don't
know how many times,
Hold on. Is that super clip chimped? Is that like Well, if that's
the Was he saying something like if that's the standard you're
using then I've my wife like a million times or something? Is
that Is that what's going on there? I just I'm I'm sitting here
and I'm like, "Dude, if I hope that's not like turbo clip chimped."
That'd be really weird. No, I'm I'm fine with it. Like if you
>> saying that you've your wife? >> Yeah, if you
think that me rolling over in the morning and she's asleep and
waking her up with some this cave Well, I mean, if she's unconscious?
She's asleep deep for sure. That's a Oh, they
Hold on.
They literally have a dynamic where that's pre-consented to.
That's the thing. That's Andrew's just being >> unconscious,
right?
Yeah. If she had too much to drink and passed out? >> Yeah,
we've done that too when we're both drunk. Yeah. Well, I mean,
where she passed out?
Andrew Wilson's a
I mean, I Rachel's literally come out and said that's our That's
the thing we do. That's a thing we do. Yeah.
I wish I didn't know that. I wish I wish I could have gone through
life without knowing that, but hey.
So, Andrew had some rant about America activist. Check it out
real quick.
Moving over to Destiny, Destiny put out a tweet saying that he
would give $100,000
to the defense Tilly if she was sued for her obvious slanderous
and insane and irresponsible comment.
Does this guy just have like a fetish for paying lawyers now?
Is that what's going on?
Why why would you offer that? Why would you just offer a hundred
dude? I don't know how to look at that other than is
the DG's going to have to foot the bill? Yeah, well well. This
was echoed by America who
Destiny has been a part of. I'm not sure if he is now. I'm guessing
probably, but I don't know that for sure. But just remember that
this is a
for a progressive organization which really hates my guts in
a big way
because I wreck all of their members all the time in debates
and they look really stupid. Now, I'm just going to point this
out so that you understand the blatant insane
I guess he's talking about the Erudite debate. It didn't go well
for Erudite,
I love that Erudite's like thing after the fact. The thing she
came back with was yeah, like maybe I didn't do well in that
debate, but I got all the best
>> that was brutal.
I don't know if I watched that [__] on
She had There's some clip from her stream where she comes back
after the debate and she's just like, yeah, maybe I didn't do
well, but I got all the best clips. Bro,
>> Destiny is under accusation
of sharing
per view that he shot at home a tape that he shot at home
to another who he was interested in sparking a relationship up
with and
did this without the consent of the he shot the original tape
with.
I mean, there's multiple allegations like that. Yeah. >> See,
it's In fact, it's I mean, it's just very difficult to call it
allegations anymore when
like he it's not really allegations. Like all the proof is out.
All the things you would want for proof in in any like
any case like this, it's just all proven out, right? There's
a I know, I've debated her before. The overwhelming irony
of an organization
which would enhance that they would defend
who made the accusation that I am the R
while their mascot and head of their
is alleged to have done these horrible things in regards to consent
and is widely known on the internet allegedly as a
>> Say it, Andrew. past Oh, it's past. They call him Pastiny
for a reason. >> Right. Too bad. >> Due to the fact
that he's been accused of impropriety, I don't know how many
times with how many different many of by their own admission
mentally ill.
Now, of course, this is all alleged, but the lore there is very
deep and much of it he wouldn't even run away from versus
It's really not alleged. Like it's it's just really not. I have
not ever even had an accusation of impropriety.
I'm not even talking about the R word or SA or any of that.
I haven't even had an accusation of impropriety
from any online ever because there is no impropriety to accuse
me of. I would want to see people go back at
We Do we get a response to this from
Who responds to this?
I just want to hear what the response would be.
Cuz you've got like a couple options. It's I guess maybe saying
that
the multiple women who accused Destiny of doing this without
consent are all lying in tandem?
This is before we ever get to inappropriate touching or any of
the crazy that many often are accused of. I've not even been
accused of having an inappropriate text message.
And yet the organization,
the organization which has a mascot
which is under accusation for consent-based crimes.
This is the organization that wants to fight me tooth and nail.
This is what He's talking about America, yes. Sorry, it's very
clear that he's talking about America. That's why he's quote
That's why the quote tweet is America tour. Right? That's why
Italian progressives are going on here.
They're lunatics. They're lunatics. Doesn't this dude flip out
and call women on his show?
Um yeah, he's not talking about words. He's talking about like
actual consent violations, right? Yeah.
Why What
Uh I believe they're accusing me of some impropriety when their
mascot has done multiple like multiple consent violations, has
multiple accusations from multiple women over years. And your
response is, "Doesn't this guy call
I What is the purpose of that response?
Huh? What?
Undermine his claim by showing him Pixie? No, I don't think he
undermined his I mean, he No, I don't think he undermined his
claim at all. Wait. No, no, no, no, no. Hold on. He thinks that
Destiny did all those crimes and that every woman that was willing
to interact in the that way with Destiny deserves
So, you could He didn't undermine it. He's like, "No, Dessi definitely
violated your consent. You deserve it for having a relationship
with Destiny." That's his position. That's been his position
from the very beginning. That's a That's a counter position as
well, by the way.
From what I recall. Okay.
Brain, could you find the Z response?
Oh, yeah. I've I've got the ASU stuff as well, if we want to
cover more America [__] Which maybe we jump right
into that. I could see it. So, Z posted this tweet yesterday.
I've got like the tweet and I've got
like her reaction, her YouTube video, I think. Okay. Let's read
the original allegation here. Unfortunately, @ASU canceled our
America tour event that we had scheduled on Monday with @TheOmniLiberal,
but we are still showing up on campus anyway. As a result, we
are filing a lawsuit against Arizona State University for violating
our First Amendment rights. The same day it was canceled, Mrs.
Erica Kirk at Elon Musk Can we Can we get this updated to Miss
or Miz Erica Kirk? I showed up at the campus and complained about
America. Unironically, in that same meeting, Erica scolded her
chapter members for not countering our event. She told them to
stop speaking about Iran and just to talk about freedom of speech.
Public universities don't get to decide who can speak. Every
campus, same playbook. TPUSA applying pressure behind the scenes
to shut us down. We know exactly how this works, and unfortunately
for them, we're not going away. We're fully prepared to take
them to court, too. I'm shocked that that Erica Kirk would mention
Unf- America. That would be really stupid of her. Let's see what
this video actually says.
Oh, she shows some emails in the video. Okay, okay. I put the
kids to bed, and then I thought to myself, you guys are in our
backyard.
And I was really frustrated that you guys weren't able to have
the counter table-ing for the Unf- America tour, and that we
kicked you off. Uh especially because we have some really good
people that could be on campus to counter program that.
What? So, she's literally Hold on.
not at all her applying pressure for them not to be there,
My voice is not going to do well today, I don't think. That What
she's saying is, I want you guys to have people here or call
us and we'll send people to go and debate them.
Right? That's like the whole point. Is that not what she's saying?
She's not saying don't know like refuse to have them. She's saying
I want people counter programming them. I want people going and
like literally debating them. Yeah, no to answer your question,
my husband isn't here to say whether or not we should get one
with the wrong.
I would love for him to be here right now and he'd tell us if
we should or should not.
I would love it. I miss his voice more than anybody in this world.
You know, it's frustrating when you have people speaking for
him. I can say I have the sentiment for that.
But thank the good lord that we have a bunch of his videos that
we can look back on. And it's like chapters like this, I have
to commend you. This is amazing.
All of you guys sitting here together having debate, discourse,
dialogue.
That's what Turning Point USA is about and that's what I want
it to continue. So, when you ask what's our stance on the war,
what's our stance on that, I actually would prefer that we have
these types of discussions where our stance is on freedom of
speech and I want you guys to all continue to just
What? Okay, that's
Okay, that's weird. Oh, we don't take Our stance is on freedom
of speech. Okay, but you're debating, so you should have a stance
on the other issues. No?
I don't This person can't run this organization. They need to
get a different person running this organization before it
She literally can't She could be She could be like a figurehead
in some way, but she should not be the person going around talking
to chapters about anything. I hope they've got people who know
how to do [__] Now, let's listen to the beginning
again where she mentions the America tour. I think what she's
saying is I want I want us to bring people to debate against
them. No?
I put the kids to bed and I talked to myself, "You guys are in
our backyard."
And I was really frustrated that you guys weren't able to have
the counter tabling for the Unfuck America tour and that really
pissed the counter tabling for the Unfuck America tour and that
really pissed me off. pissed me off. Uh especially because we
have some really good people that could be on campus to counter
program them. especially cuz we have some really good people
to be on campus to counter program them. So, she's saying I would
I would like if you guys as a part of this Turning Point chapter
be like ready and willing and getting get you set up to go and
counter program this this protest movement to us. So, literally
it's like talking about competing with them, right? Like that's
talking about competing with them. That's literally
That is quite literally the
exact thing. No, no, no, no.
What Z is implying is that because Erika Kirk pressured them
to, right?
complained about Unfuck America. Ironically in that same meeting
Erika Kirk, "Oh, well, maybe there's a video here that's not
this one where she complains about them and says they shouldn't
be allowed to talk."
Yeah, oh, dude, this video is like literally not This is not
the case.
This video is not remotely what's going on here.
Uh so goofy, man. Okay. There are no There are no emails in this
video, but I think she did another video here, okay? So, she
did a YouTube video about this. I really did not want to have
to make this video. Let's see what's going on in this YouTube
video real quick. Um and in fact, I actually did every really
did not want to have to make this YouTube video. I did not want
>> have to make this video. And in fact, I actually did
everything in my power to not have to make this video. But I
guess uh here we are. If this is the first time you're seeing
me, my name is E, I'm a political operative from rural Nevada,
and just over a year ago, I started the largest counter-organization
Turning Point USA on the left national ground game. Before Charlie
Kirk died, we started a college campus tour, which was against
his American Comeback Tour, called the It's a very You've probably
seen us online and maybe even at your college campus. And our
first stop for our spring tour was set to be this Monday at Arizona
State University. In the past Did she have like
Did she get like um
Did she get like a crown put in or have a root canal before this?
was against his American Comeback Tour, called the American Tour.
You've probably seen us online and maybe She's got like a lisp
going or something. It sounds like she might be numbed up. And
our first stop for our spring tour was set to be Our first stop
for our spring tour was set to be What's going on here? E this
Monday at Arizona State University. In the past 48 hours
that has Dude, what? What is happening?
In the last couple of hours uh has been canceled by the university.
Um which is curious to us because we found out that the event
was going to be canceled shortly after our president of our college
chapter went to a Turning Point in closed-door meeting at State
University to invite the Turning Point USA students and was faced
with Erica Kirk, who just Wait, hold on.
>> Did he inform them he was recording that meeting or
is this like new tech?
>> There's no way this guy is recording without anyone's
under consent or knowledge under the table. There's no way. There's
no way that's what happened here, is there? >> Just happened
to have shown up to campus and would just happen to be in that
meeting. This is what she said. I put the kids to bed and I locked
myself. You guys are in our backyard
and I was really frustrated that you guys weren't able to have
the counter tabling for the UN of America tour and we could not.
Shortly after we received an email saying that our event would
be canceled because of us not within their 14-day rule of applying
for a permit even though we were within that 14-day rule and
also we have this screenshot right here that says >> Thank
you for sending. Your event is confirmed. Let me know if you
have any
Bro, did she even attempt to
Did she even a Hannah
Okay, are you like trying to get this person harassed or
Is this There's no way this is real,
This is so tra What the [__] are you
That our event was a >> Her Her full name is right there.
Now, you could obviously go and find any of her other [__]
Why would you do such a horrible job of censoring this? Yeah,
I see we carry the flame on the shirt. I see it. And also we
have this screenshot right here Oh, this would be Hannah Mabrook
as well. mainx1.asu.edu
and dude to Jude f Bro, what the [__] This is even
worse. Bro, what the [__] Is this serious? Is this
a serious person? Everything she attempted to censor here is
not censored even remotely. That's absolutely wild. That's crazy.
>> here that says that our event was approved. And then
shortly after we found out that we would not be allowed to have
our event on the ASU campus. We found out that Turning Point
USA would be having Jack Posobiec at their closed door meeting
closed door meeting on Monday. even though that was never planned.
I believe at my core, because I have evidence to prove it, that
Charlie Kirk never stood for free speech, and neither does Turning
Point USA. That I mean, that that's true. Are you going to point
out that Charlie Kirk spent
hours and hours and hours, endless hours of his time, trying
to make sure Nick Fuentes was deplatformed everywhere? Because
yeah, we have all of the evidence of that. We have Republican
influencers who've leaked their DMs of Charlie Kirk telling them,
"Hey, don't platform this guy. Don't talk to this guy. You can't
talk to this guy. He's the worst guy. Never talk to this guy."
Yeah, he didn't stand for free speech at
That's true. that Charlie Kirk never stood for free speech, and
neither does Turning Point USA. That is an illusion. Here's the
the video you put out here is literally them saying they want
to combat your speech with speech. They're arguing for free speech.
That's what Erika Kirk is doing there.
This is just like a total lie.
thing. It doesn't matter whether they stand for free speech or
not, because at the end of the day, it is our right to express
our freedom of speech on every public university campus across
this country. I'm sure that ASU thought that we were just going
to take this lying down, but unfortunately for them, there are
people that believe in this case, and that will represent us.
This isn't just an attack against National Ground Game. This
is an attack against Democrats all across the country, and conservatives
are winning that battle. Here's the thing, we cannot do this
on our own. We need you to step up and help us in this fight,
because we can't take on the Republican establishment all by
ourselves. So, please go to our website nationalgroundgame.com,
chip in anything you can, sign up to volunteer, and remember
to follow me to hopefully America. That's bro, okay. So, she's
just looking for donations. Got it. Got >> you can. Got
it. But, dude, that's that's crazy. She's literally just lying.
Uh is there more footage somewhere where Erika Kirk complains
about America? She's arguing she wants to counter message you,
implying she doesn't want your event canceled at all, at all.
The video you posted doesn't support what you're saying at all.
It doesn't support It doesn't, not even a little bit. Yeah, Z
is just lying about
TPUSA like getting them their event canceled. And they apparently
got an event canceled. I've no idea why their event is canceled,
to be honest with you. I've no [__] idea. Anyway,
I was just weird that It's just weird. It's like not supported
at all. She's implying Erica Kirk applied
And she didn't. It's
It's wild. They booked Jack Posobiec on the same day for a TPUSA
thing.
Wait, she did say that.
Does that not imply then, if Jack Posobiec's going to be there
>> even though we were within that 14-day rule. And also,
we have this screenshot right here that says that our event campus,
we found out that Turning Point USA would be having Jack Posobiec
at their closed-door meeting, closed-door meeting on Monday,
even though that was never planned. I believe at my core, because
I have evidence to prove it,
Charlie Kirk never stood for free
I mean, that's just true, but hold on. So, Jack Posobiec's going
to be there at a closed-door meeting. Pick up the mic.
It It looks like they actually planned an event there to make
sure their chapter people weren't going to your
Oh, what?
I'm confused by everything Z does, to be honest with you. It's
just always confusing to me. Okay, hold on. We got a little bit
more going on here. Racism controversy, finances. During the
height of the America tour between January 1st, 2025 and September
30th, 2025, the National Ground Game PAC
uh $723,807
in receipts and $693,000
in expenses. Between January and August 2025, National Ground
Game reported paying almost $300,000 or 42.4%
of it uh its total expenditures to Soul Strategies. In the wake
of the controversy over Koen Sanchez's management of the tour,
some influencers questioned the necessity of such a large a large
percentage of revenues going to the organizers.
Um we covered all of this stuff. I do think it's weird that it
just all goes to like just this ease thing by itself, but eh,
I I just don't have any more to do on it for for content. Okay.
Man, that was shorter than I thought. I thought that was going
to be a longer
It just but it just seems like she's making this up. I Wait,
there is some other stuff though. Hold on. Did I grab the r/destiny
thread?
Somebody sent me a thread from this Hold on. Um
ASU Let me see if I can find this. ASU cancellation if it happens
in reverse.
The story Erika Karr complaint The story is Erika Karr complained
to Arizona State University. They canceled up America's talk
and now a TPUSA event starring Jack Posobiec and Tucker Carlson's
ex-top writer is taking its
Imagine if something like this happened in reverse. A large liberal
political commentator active activist saw a conservative event
happening at a university in their backyard and complained to
the university. The university cancels the conservative and the
liberal gets an event there last
Well, hold on. Isn't the idea that Jack Posobiec is there, isn't
that because they want to
Wouldn't that suggest like the opposite that they literally wanted
to get an event scheduled with the university where they would
be competing with you? Isn't that the whole point? I thought
it was, but okay.
>> Conservative media and centrist conservative alt media
across the board would be covering this as the left attacking
free speech and conservatives. From Fox to Newsmax to OAN to
NYP to the New York Post to all the online commentators, all
the way on down the chain to boner for Trump 69420 on X, the
everything app.
Would be talking about it for the next week, month. They'd be
bringing it up for years. All the centrist would have their Dude,
really? Not just Soul Strategies, there's another sketchy company
being paid by America's PAC,
Pranayama Strategies.
Okay. Uh all the So, they're just complaining that everybody
would bring it up. Rogan would bring it up for sure. He'd probably
have the Cancel Conservative on. The conservative world would
stop to focus on this university and their horrific wokeness
and attack on free speech.
Well, I think Z is trying to like replicate that, but the She
just doesn't seem to have any evidence that this is actually
what
at all. And the Jack event is scheduled for 6:00 p.m. and their
tour thing was allegedly supposed to be at 1:00 p.m. Oh,
Oh, 11:30 a.m. to 1:00 p.m. at the student pavilion. So, it's
not in the same place and it's not at the same
but she thinks they were canceled for the Jack Posobiec thing.
>> Destiny is definitely in the top 10 of influential political
left political commentators on the internet today. This should
be a news story. This should have Luke Beasley and Brian Tyler
Cohen and Dean Withers and the other Dean Withers, whatever the
[__] his name is, Parker that would be, and Midas
Touch and everyone with an audience saying something about this.
Yeah, I
Does that not say something about Z's credibility? I I feel like
everybody looks at that and they see the video, which is not
saying at all what she's implying,
right? And they go, "Oh, I'm not touching this. I'm literally
not touching this." Um this is funny in and of itself, but we're
not going to We're not going to get too much into it. That's
just very funny that somebody would say that. That's Okay. By
the way,
>> I just such Okay, maybe the liberal
There's a whole bunch of Okay, nothing. I
Dude, I should get out of this. This should This should have
a piece in places like CNN and NBC. This should be a call to
action, but it won't be. Nobody will even know it happened except
us. Probably not even a show item on Livin' Learn, the only liberal
show on Twitch. Dude, what?
Why do these people have like claim some ownership over Livin'
Learn, a show that has nothing to do with their community?
It's so weird. It's just bizarre.
Guys, we're like the liberal authorities and and and you have
to you're the liberal show, you have to listen to us.
Bro, make a liberal show then. What the [__] What
the heck, man? This should be a call to action. Oh, this should
have a piece in places like CNN and NBC. This should be a call
to action, but it won't be. Nobody will even know it happened
except us. Okay. God. Probably not and even an item on Livin'
Learn. Hasan may mention it to Dank or Destiny, that's about
it.
I mean, I'm not even bringing Destiny up. It's literally just
Z is like totally unreliable. Do you remember when she tried
to paint it as like Myron and Andrew totally them over? And then
you go and look at the negotiations and she's completely unreasonable.
She is like absolutely at fault entirely for up the debate between
Myron and Andrew and Adam and Destiny, right? She totally bungled
it completely. And I'm I feel like this is going to be the same
thing. You'll find out that she totally something up somehow
or someone around her totally something up and she's at fault
and she's trying to make a story out of it. She's trying to sensationalize
it. The improp- impropriety of the media. And remember this the
next time a conservative brings brings up [snorts] how mainstream
media is liberal or how conservatives don't get a fair shake
in media. Destiny being a victim of conservative cancel culture
won't even get a mention. Jordan Pete- Peterson's entire career
got launched because some college kids screech at him without
anyone official even canceling any of his appearances.
Like came in and screamed over him. Right? They
I'm sure that could happen with somebody
You don't really duplicate like viral moments like that though.
EG really is the most impressed oppressed minority.
The biggest thing to come of the from this is if Z actually sues
ASU. It's pretty sure it happened and should be a big larger
noteworthy thing, but the thing that will actually make changes
the lawsuit. Oh, they put out a press release. Hold on.
MP Arizona National Ground Game in partnership with the Unfuck
America Tour is announcing its intent to file a lawsuit against
Arizona State University following what we believe to be clear
violations of the First Amendment. Despite the development, we
want to be clear. We are still coming to Arizona University.
We will continue to show up, engage students, and exercise our
First Amendment rights to the fullest extent permitted under
the law. Efforts to silence or restrict lawful expression will
only strengthen our resolve.
I don't know, man. Crowdfunding the lawsuit? They are going to
try to crowdfund the lawsuit, right? No? I would imagine, I don't
know. It's I guess it's fine.
the idea that they canceled this event so they could do the Jack
Posobiec one doesn't make any [__] sense, right?
That they don't overlap in time at all? Like she's she's just
lying about everything going on here. Maybe they could take $100,000
of the money they normally get for a free lawsuit. I don't know.
I don't man.
I just I would want to see some proof. I would want to see some
proof of the things she's saying instead of just like one vague
email where she literally doesn't censor any of the people involved.
Okay.
I would want to just see more proof. This seems very fishy to
me. Very fishy, very weird.
Very strange. Want to stop Siege about Destiny. I agree with
you, man.
I do think this stuff's interesting though. Like I do find the
Unfuck America Tour very interesting.
Guy is a joke and I want everyone to abandon and forget him.
Well, I don't
I Listen, he's got like a cult-like thing going on there, okay?
That's probably not happening. If you need If you need that,
you're probably not getting that, okay? Just saying. Woo! Probably
not happening.
All right.